y a une chose c'est un smartphone qui
est dédié gaming on a un instinct
dragonne 845 on a lui giga drame
le soc est cadencé fond du court je
cherche des herbes je n'en trouve pas je
postionne sur l'écran est une
catastrophe
[Musique]
aujourd'hui on parle du réseau fon de
rider rider est une promesse
lorsque vous allez voir conçu pour le
travail parfait pour le jeu ce qui du
coup pourrait laisser penser à croire
que ce razer faune de n'est pas aux
smartphones de gaming est avant tout un
flagship fait pour le travail fait pour
une utilisation professionnelle mais est
également bon pour le gaming
en réalité c'est pas exactement ça la
réalité c'est que razer razer prononcé
comme ça très à l'américaine
razer est là pour draguer dans notre
public que public gamer
bien évidemment que wilders est une
marque pour les gamer ça on le sait
c'est très clair néanmoins ils veulent
élargir leur cible dire vous achetez le
réseau fon vous avez de la performance
vers un smartphone qui est vraiment
excellent qui va tourner super bien et
notamment pour le multimédia mais ça je
vous le montrer dans quelques instants
mais il est aussi excellent pour lui
évident qu'au final ce visiophone est-ce
qu'il est excellent est-ce qu'il est
très bon et surtout c'est pas très
important est ce qu'il est meilleur la
concurrence asus rog phone chimie bragg
sharks et sans parler du nord plaît
voilà la boîte riser phone 2 alors j'ai
déjà sorti le smartphone bien évidemment
si vous le montrer d'ici quelques
minutes
quant au second en tout cas voici en
tout cas la botte de réserve j'aime
beaucoup le packaging toujours très très
bien léché de la part de razer petit
logo voilà c'est vraiment très très bien
fait toujours extrêmement bien pensée
flaccide gaming le réseau fon quand vous
ouvrez se situe juste là vous avez une
petite encoche qui trouve fois que vous
ouvrez hop vous arriver là directement
vous avez tous des infos sans votre
rider funky voir carte sim pour l'ouvrir
c'est toujours hyper bien packagées
j'adore vraiment l'univers de riser
parce que ils sont vraiment vraiment
fort en marketing vous avez un
adaptateur parce qu'on n'a pas de prise
jack sur le smartphone vous venez
l'acteur usb type c'est vers mini jack
vous avez votre câble de recharge votre
moitié ici pour recharger et c'est à peu
près tout par contre c'est extrêmement
bien fait c'est très joli
super packaging comme d'habitude
cinemizer alors le smartphone il n'a pas
changé énormément par rapport au réseau
fon qu'on avait par contre que la
première version du réseau fon
c'est un objet qui est assez gros c'est
un gros cube par contre je trouve quand
même bon très sympa il est pas mal en
termes de prise en main c'est pas idéal
il est très gros franchement on va pas
avoir la meilleure prise en main
néanmoins il fait son effet ya quelques
points qui ont été améliorés prouve ici
sur le côté votre capteur d'empreintes
digitales sur votre bouton principal ça
reconnaissait déjà c'est un truc qui
marche très bien il est hyperactif il
marche super bien ça c'est franchement
hyper cool en bas vous avez votre
prisonniers de l'équipe c'est sur le
côté vous avez juste deux boutons de
volume situé au centre c'est très
minimaliste tiroirs de cartes sim
ici au dessus petit micro et la
jouissance côté y'a pas grand chose
c'est vraiment hyper hyper minimaliste
capteurs proximité caméra ici pour faire
vos photos haut parleurs haut parleurs
vous avez deux gros par leur ambassade
on reste toujours dans un smartphone
dédié au gaming mais surtout au
multimédia
vous avez ici votre gros module photo on
va en parler d'ici quelques instants
c'est surtout un dos en verre ça c'est
vraiment la nouveauté cette année c'est
franchement cool et puis surtout vous
avez khroma avec votre logo qui va
scintiller de mille feux avec l'effet
khroma ça c'est vraiment cool
c'est une question logiciels en fait
vous rentrez dans votre smartphone vous
allez dans vos paramètres khroma est là
vous allez pouvoir complètement ajuster
les faits chrome à choisir la couleur il
a moyens on peut le mettre en élevé
comme ça hop
même si elle a blessé un petit peu la
batterie ça va beaucoup mieux ressortir
en vidéo ils changent de couleur vous
pouvez vraiment vraiment mia paramétrer
un vous avez différents modes
respiration il va venir me g comme sur
une respiration statique explique qu'il
a changé c'est ce que j'aime et ce que
ça vraiment vraiment vraiment sympa si
nous faisons respiration pouvait venir
choisir vous même la couleur enfin voila
je trouve ça vraiment cool voyez la
place rouge plutôt à bordeaux plutôt sur
le bleu plutôt sur la fin vous avez
compris le truc
jusque là je vous apprends rien mais je
trouve que c'est vraiment sympa et ça
permet vraiment d'aller encore plus dans
l'univers de gaming et là dessus c'est
pareil rivers a vraiment fait un
excellent travail puisqu'on est là on va
regarder l'écran alors l'écran
franchement pour moi c'est un des gros
gros gros gros gros gros point positif
de ce réseau fon
il est tout simplement excellent on peut
regretter d'avoir un écran uniquement
lcd pas d'écran oled de notre côté on a
un taux de rafraîchissement de 120 hertz
et ça aujourd'hui sont le oled ça ne
passe pas dont vous avez ce qu'ils
appellent un écran ultra beau chaude 120
m
on pouvait jusqu'à 100 variable vous
n'êtes pas du tout obligé d'être en 120
hertz tous les jours pas nécessité mais
si vous voulez en tout cas pour gagner
de la fluidité de pavant de latence par
saccades pourrait le faire sans écran
qui est extrêmement bien calibré qui est
très lumineux qui a une résolution de
2560 1440 elle un écran de 5,72 pouces
et vous avez devant un corning gorilla
glass 5c du format 16 9ème ici il n'ya
pas de format pas de 19 9e pas de 18,5
ne vienne ici c'est du 16/9 pourquoi
tout simplement parce que le 16/9 c'est
selon riser le format le mieux adapté
aux jeux vidéo et même pour de la vidéo
franchement voyez ça pas dire cros pdt
chose qui est complètement optimisé pour
me regarder des films des séries le 16/9
c'est juste parfait
donc là je montre uniquement
l'expérience pour regarder la vidéo sur
youtube sont des flics c'est
complètement optimisé parce que vous
avez un écran qui est compatible hd r ça
marche super bien
deux hauts parleurs en façade vous avez
station de spatialisation un son qui
arrive vraiment de la face ça c'est
vraiment un très très gros point positif
quand vous avez dans vos paramètres
paramètres sont vous avez vos paramètres
dolby atmos qui sont ici et là vous
allez pouvoir régler pas mal de choses
réhausser les basses faire votre
équaliseur maison vous allez pouvoir
choisir son des films sont la musique
personnalisé vous faites ce que vous
voulez vous a déjà des prêts cet
existant en fonction de vos goûts
bon ça ça dépend vraiment mais vraiment
des goûts de chacun pour après vous avez
pas mal d'infos explorer 2010 à petit
c'est grâce à tout ce qui est vraiment
très très bien fait et ça en expérience
audio c'est vraiment top
d'une manière générale lo'jo et quand
même
en bien là dessus les médiums sont bien
définis les aigus sont assez claires
vous avez des baux grave
ici pas de trop de base d'un côté
comment voulez vous que des petits haut
parleurs comme ça développe basse c'est
pas le cas par contre ça marche quand
même franchement super bien entre potes
est super cool ici sur le dos je dis
vous avez votre adaptateur usb thil
s'est prise jack et ça franchement ça
marche du feu de dieu
la qualité audio est vraiment bien et
même lorsque vous allez mettre un petit
casque sur votre tête
c'est complètement où c'est un peu fort
mais le spectre et là vous avez vraiment
de la grave grave de la basse c'est
vraiment super beau degré belle
précision une vraie belle maîtrise là
dessus
par ailleurs au voc sur les offres en
tout cas tout de suite de ce que je vous
en montre c'est vraiment un smartphone
qui est complètement dédié multimédia le
gaming par extension mais vraiment pour
regarder des vidéos pour avoir une belle
qualité
et ça ne serait ce que pour avoir un
format 16 9ème il ya plein de marques
nous proposent des formats 19/9 18
points 5/9 c'est devenu un standard
aujourd'hui mais au final il lorsque
vous prenez des films que vous les
regardez vous relais des séries ils sont
au format 16/9 des jeux vidéo pour la
plupart sont au format 16/9 avoir des
très grands écrans format 19/9 c'est
bien par contre on ne me veut dire
croupe est on obligé vers bouffer un peu
d'image sur le haut sur le bas souvent
c'est pas optimisé il ya des grands
écrans ok mais là pour le coup le format
16/9 c'est juste ce qu'il faut on
pourrait se dire je veux diagonale plus
grande mais franchement vu la bête vous
prendriez diagonale plus grande vous
auriez un monstre dans votre poche ça ne
servirait strictement rien donc pour
l'instant pour le multimédia pour
regarder des vidéos netflix youtube ce
que vous voulez écouter de la musique
spotify deezer ce que vous voulez ça
marche extrêmement bien et là dessus
either a fait vraiment un énorme boulot
c'est vraiment un smartphone qui est
complètement optimisé dédié pour lier me
perds fluide hyper agréable
tiens voilà hop un espèce de taré la
clim car déjà dessus on va éviter de se
faire une idée tout de suite c'est
vraiment hyper bien voyez il ya
absolument aucune latence aucun lag
c'est très très très très fluide c'est
vraiment hyper hyper appréciable et à
une chute
c'est un smartphone qui est dédié gaming
on a un instinct draps
845 on a lui giga drame
le soc est cadencé faut que je cours
vite le ton est cadencé jusqu'à 2,8
gigahertz
ça marche très très bien côté graphique
ont aidé j'ai pu c'est une adreno 630 et
ce qui est super bien là dessus il va
chauffer un petit peu assez légèrement
s'est pas complètement dingue on a du
refroidissement à chambre à vapeur
on a 8 gigas de ram lp ddr4 x on à 64
giga de stockage extensible jusqu'à 1
des rats ça c'est franchement cool je ne
trouve pas d'issue je vais me faire
défoncer c'est vraiment dommage en tout
cas ce qui est bien et ce qu'on voit là
dessus c'est que c'est hyper fluide pour
avoir joué plusieurs fois je continue à
vraiment apprécier ce smartphone je
trouve complètement optimisé pour le jeu
vidéo
je cherche des herbes je n'en trouve pas
je positionne sur l'écran est une
catastrophe
au secours en fait ce qui est assez
surprenant lorsqu'on joue comme ça c'est
qu'ils chauffent mais ici au niveau de
l'appareil photo on le sent la chaleur
est vraiment ici ici en bas de ce côté
là il ya so lu ment pas de chaleur mais
là c'est chaud alors lorsque vous jouez
comme ça vous sentez si un petit regain
de chaleur ça vous choque les doigts en
hiver ça peut être sympa
bon c'est pas complètement dingue non
pas les températures extrêmes ça reste
franchement convenable en termes de
performances on arrive à un score de 280
4644 sûr en tout c'est extrêmement
convenable ça va très bien de toute
façon le stand ragon 845 est extrêmement
bien maîtrisée c'est pas le plus rapide
en tout cas un benchmark sur en tout
mais il va très bien pour du gaming pour
plein de choses pour tout ce que vous
voulez c'est un smartphone qui fera
franchement bien faire au niveau de tout
début je trouve aussi franchement
excellent avec sa batterie de 4000
militants paire eur alors c'est
excellent oui et non parce que ça va
vraiment dépendre de vous de la façon
dont vous jouez et du mode de jeu vous
allez choisir je vous la fais très
courte si vous jouez à des jeux en 60
hertz vous aurez absolument aucun
problème
votre smartphone pour utilisation
standard vous allez le garder une
journée me très facilement ça fonctionne
si par contre vous monte tout de suite
on 120 hertz mais vous êtes sur des jeux
qui utilisent du 120 hertz tout de suite
l'autonomie va vraiment baisser
drastiquement très rapidement et vous
allez perdre une demi journée
d'autonomie vous à être plus sur une
journée autonomie voire un petit peu
moins si vous faites vraiment des
grosses sessions gaming ça peut être un
petit peu le point négatif de notre côté
on a un écran qui va consommer davantage
si vous jouez beaucoup vous allez
forcément taper un peu plus d'autonomie
on peut pas non plus trop loin
entendez par contre point extrêmement
positif vous avez de la recharge rapide
qualcomm coûte charge 4.0 c'est dur à
dire cool comme cockpit charge très
compliqué à dire mais ça fait
franchement rien à faire donc ça c'est
aussi un point très positif le fait
d'avoir cette recharge rapide et en plus
de ça dont anvers vous avez de la
recharge sans fil
c'est aussi un point positif et pour une
recharge complète il vous faut un petit
peu moins d'une heure et demie ça
franchement c'est aussi super cool
maintenant il ya tout qui va sûrement
bien puisqu'on parle de puissance de
performance d'autonomie et de jeu c'est
cortex alors dans cortex vous allez
avoir plein de jeux différents et
pouvoir télécharger plein de jeux hyper
connue des jeux pas connu des jeux
gratuits les jeux payants il ya vraiment
plein plein plein de choses et vous avez
votre boost heure de jeu avec vos jeux
et vous allez pouvoir ensuite lire
complètement paramétrer vos jeux je vous
prends un exemple de pub jmobil vous
allez baisser la fréquence de l'horloge
du processeur que vous allez baisser la
fréquence de l'image au contraire si
vous voulez vraiment des performances
hyper élevé vous allez monter jusqu'à
120 m
le processeur vous allez faire tourner à
fond et forcément ça va consommer
énormément il ya un compromis au milieu
ça dépend des jeux ça dépend vraiment
complètement des jeux et ça peut même le
calibre et d'une façon générale et je
vous dis après le calibrer jeu par jeu
en mode personnalisé
donc ça c'est franchement super bien
vous pouvez aussi faire soit désactiver
les notifications lorsque vous jouez
pour ne pas être dérangé il ya pas mal
de petits paramètres qui au final font
vraiment de ce smartphone un excellent
smartphone de gaming
on va mettre en parler de l' os on est
sur un android 8.1 oreo on a quasiment
d'android stocks
on est juste un ovale allshare prime qui
vous permet de venir personnaliser votre
smartphone mais qui est très léger
vous avez ici tous les paramètres de
votre nova convenir personnaliser
complètement votre bureau dire
personnalisés tout ce que vous voulez
c'est franchement bien vote donc vos
dossiers votre mode nuit ça c'est
vraiment cool
vous avez également une boutique de
thèmes ici beaucoup de thèmes dans
l'univers du gaming en dit forcément
chez razer et ça vous permet vraiment de
faire ce que vous voulez que votre
smartphone que ce soit en termes de
thèmes que ce soit au niveau du launcher
c'est vraiment hyper cool mais bon
malgré tout il reste moins de regret
c'est le fait de ne pas avoir de android
9 paille là dessus on ne comprend pas
trop en réalité on comprend pas trop
pourquoi
sur ce smartphone qui au final est
extrêmement récents pour les papas si
tout ceci sur la dernière version
d'android
bon peut-être qu'il va y avoir une mise
à jour d'ici quelques temps en tout cas
pour l'instant
voilà ceci étant dit rassurez vous ça
marche très bien
c'est vraiment sûre d'elle un petit peu
chipoter on va maintenant par les photos
et oh vous avez un double module photo
ici deux fois 12 mégapixels le premier
c'est un grand-angle qui ouvre à f 1.75
avec une stabilisation optique vous avez
ensuite un tel objectif toujours 12
mégapixels est qu'une ouverture de f/2
points 6 ou et filmé jusqu en 4k vous
avez un doute autofocus à détection de
phase donc là c'est cool et l avant vous
avez une caméra de 8 mégapixels qui
ouvre à f 2.0 et vous pouvez filmer
jusqu'en 1080p côté photo ça reste assez
sommaire vous pouvez régler la
température ici plus chaudes plus froide
en automatique comme vous le voulez vous
avez un minuteur vous avez une grille
pour devenir découper votre photo ça bon
pourquoi pas pour moi c'est du gadget
hdr le flash quelques paramètres de base
notamment au niveau de la résolution
au niveau de la vidéo et en cas de cas
je vous le disais directement ici vous
avez le mode portrait avec quelques
paramètres de base
le mode beauté est d'ailleurs le mode
beauté vous l'avez en hauts-de-seine fi
uniquement par son amant le mode beauté
je n'aime pas du tout donc je passe vous
avez un mode panorama ça c'est cool et
vous avez le mode vidéo qui situent
juste là sur lequel vous pouvez régler
deux trois petits trucs bon c'est la
base
elle l'a photographiée en extérieur pour
moi elle fonctionne vraiment bien avec
l'autofocus à détection de phase
ça marche bien vous avez un détail c'est
vraiment pas mal les couleurs sont assez
bien rendue sont très très naturel là je
fais toujours sur la caméra principale
sur l'objectif principal vous avez
vraiment du détail
ça marche bien oui la petite toile
derrière et là je passe avec le zoom x 2
en extérieur ça marche bien c'est très
cool on a deux jolis détails pour moi
c'est vraiment quelque chose qui est
fait pour être sur l'extérieur ça voyons
est toujours sur l'extérieur pour moi
les couleurs sont bien rendus sans âge
c'est cool ça c'est la caméra de celle
fille je suis vraiment pas fan du
traitement logiciel c'est pas hyper
naturel je trouve pas ça très très joli
bon voilà c'est un choix qui est fait de
la part de riser autant la caméra
principale en extérieur est bien autant
la caméra de celle fille mon pour
passera là on est un intérieur n'y a pas
beaucoup de lumière c'est pas terrible à
l'image a du mal à se stabiliser et là
on passe directement sur la zone x 2 il
en récupère tout de suite davantage de
bruit la qualité et pas juger
sovac années en arrière vous avez chaud
en vidéo soit de la 4k soit du full hd
soit du 720p n'a pas énormément de choix
mais bon ça ça fonctionne maintenant
j'ai vraiment horreur direct sur ce
smartphone lorsque vous allez faire des
photos en mode portrait il n'est pas
possible de mettre en retard la turf.fr
sur le mode photo classique mais sans
mode portrait c'est pas possible
ce qui fait que je peux pas tester mode
portrait vu que je suis seul à tourner
que j'ai pas de canal a mal je suis tout
seul
donc si je parle retardateur ce mode
portrait c'est strictement impossible de
le faire et faire les tests donc le mode
portrait je peux pas le tester
néanmoins vous êtes sûr instinct dragon
845 fait toujours bien faire qui calcule
très bien qu'il est trop bien de ce
couple à lui j'ai cadres a absolument
pas de doute là dessus
bon normalement ça devrait le faire
chose qu'on a avec le reader phone deux
qu'on n'avait pas sur le première
version
c'est une certification ip67
c'est-à-dire étanche à l'eau et à la
poussière ne vous amusez pas pour autant
à jeter dans la mer à et vous baigner
dans la dessine avec en tout cas ce qui
est sûr c'est que six rencontres de
l'eau vous n'allez pas à craindre ça va
franchement le faire aux points colle
dessus vous avez du bluetooth 5.0 c'est
vraiment en tout cas un smartphone qui
est cool qui est vraiment dédié pour la
productivité parce qu'il ya de la
performance presque pouvez faire ce que
vous voulez il est vraiment dédié pour
le multimédia avec ce format 16 9ème qui
reste pour nous en tout cas le meilleur
ratio aujourd'hui pour la vidéo et même
pour lier mais au final est-ce que sur
l'iphone est vraiment bien positionné
par rapport à la concurrence
pour moi il reste vraiment dans games
c'est le cas de le dire il est vraiment
bien positionné l'écran est top
et si vous regardez par rapport à un
rock phone d'asus qui est aussi
excellent celui à un taux de
rafraîchissement de 120 m ce que n'a pas
le roc d'azur après avec vous vraiment
besoin de 120 hertz
on va dire que sera ce matin de gaming
c'est quand même transformé de la barre
je trouve vraiment top dites moi ce que
vous en pensez en commentaire est ce que
vous l'avez sera fun ii est ce que vous
avez déjà eu la version 1 du riser phone
est ce que vous avez d'autres
smartphones de gaming finale est ce que
vous voyez vraiment l'utilité d'abord un
smartphone de gaming en sachant qu'on
peut avoir beaucoup de performances avec
un stade ragon 845 son bar par exemple
sur un produit de huawei donc moi ce que
vous en pensez en bas en commentaire et
puis je vous invite à marie toutes vos
questions interrogations suggestions
directement sur ce smartphone en
commentaire à rester connectés parce
qu'on va continuer à parler smartphones
de gaming on va continuer
les smartphones on va les voir razer
d'ici quelques jours au cs à las vegas
donc une seule chose à faire en sa bonne
et on suit lecture d'ici là soyez sa
santé vous bien jeux 3d soit vous allez
ciao